as Christopher Nolan's first rated
Adventure in over 20 years Oppenheimer
was bound to have elements that would
make certain audience members screamish
but in some regions audiences got more
than they bargained for and the world is
not prepared the media hyped up the sex
scenes in Oppenheimer to the point where
people speculated incorrectly that there
was a 15-minute intimate scene in the
film the final results may not have been
as titulating as some people expected
but even with this awareness it is the
little to stop sensors from making
adjustments to the film not long after
the film came into scrutiny from Indian
officials due to a sex scene between
Killian Murphy's Robert Oppenheimer and
Florence Pugh's Gene tatlock where
Oppenheimer reads the heavily revered
bhagavagita further action was taken to
censor some of the film's nudity in
another scene that sees Oppenheimer and
tatlock sitting across from each other
in a hotel room or completely naked a
computer-generated black dress has been
added to Pew from some Indian and Middle
Eastern census regarding nudity this
type of censorship is considered common
practice in the regions unlike the more
adult-oriented rating given to the film
in the United States the central border
film certification in India granted a
censored film a UA rating this means
that children under the age of 12 are
permitted to see the movie if they have
a parent with them so how does that
affect the movie going experience one to
the user weighed in posting it's
pointless to watch Oppenheimer in India
blurred blocked with black bars slapped
with no smoking signs cbfc is the most
anti-cinema thing in existence for those
who made the film these racy scenes are
more important to them than some might
think everyone is entitled to their
opinions on how their nude scenes with
Murphy and Pew and Oppenheimer worked
for them many viewers have reportedly
found the reality blurring sex scene
between the two during the security
clearance hearing as oppenheimer's wife
kitty looks on to be a bit jarring
it's happening isn't it but in the eyes
of the director Christopher Nolan the
film would feel incomplete had they been
lost in an interview with Insider The
Dark Knight and Interstellar director
shared his motivation for including sex
scenes in the film something largely
avoided prior in his filmography he told
the outlet well when you look at
oppenheimer's life and you look at his
story that aspect of his life the aspect
of his sexuality his way with women the
charm that he exuded is an essential
part of his story many of the directors
previous films were PG-13 and as such
they were largely absent of any sensual
moments but for the real life story of
such an integral figure in the world's
history it appears Nolan wanted to be
sure the audience understood him as best
they could he further explained how Gene
tatlog's position as a communist made a
major impact on oppenheimer's life down
the line so perceiving their
relationship through the right lens was
crucial to understanding his later
endeavors
no then added it felt very important to
understand their relationship and to
really see inside it and understand what
made it tick without being Coy or
elusive about it but to try to be
intimate the filmmaker also believed
that the talents of Murphy and Pew
helped make his job easier when planning
out these moments while the final
results may not have worked for all
audiences hopefully the overarching
message of Oppenheimer isn't lost over a
distracting CGI dress
[Music]
foreign